Rolo we're here at the Phoenix cinema in
London and we're here for the screening
and QA Paul booked out now you play a
character called Jacob why don't you
tell us a little bit about him okay well
basically Jacob is this young guy he he
lives in this little apartment block
above below actually below Ailey and
this woman mrs. Nicholls
he's busy quite a quite an introvert
carotene is very shy there's not much
confidence and you know it's just the
whole film about him sort of coming out
of his shell discovering who he is that
with the help of Bailey and what
attracted you to playing that character
well basically I mean you know I kind of
it's a nice guy his lines are his
dialogue is quite easy to come to grips
with you know I mean like it's a it's
someone that's not too difficult to play
John I mean so I just thought why not
now the other leads in the film it's
actually their first one of them it's
their first film full stop and the other
one it's their first feature film now
you've been involved in lots of
different productions over the years for
an acting since you were a kid but it's
your lead as an ad or your first feature
as an adult did that add or take away
any pressure when you on set working
with other people who didn't have as
much experience I mean to be honest I
was just really I was really excited
about doing it you know because as you
say it was my first lead as I sort of
grown up ish grown-up but you know there
wasn't really any pressure because it
was such a nice bunch of people you know
what he was so chilled out and there was
it was just like you know it's like a
family really enterprise so there's no
pressure to loved it every minute it's
great
were there any kind of challenges or
happy accidents that happen body was
shooting I have to say the scene where I
had to speak French I was so petrified
abox
I didn't know when it was taking place
and I I thought it was ages away and
then they told me all you got to do it
the next day and I'm my friend she's
joke and I was going to be actually
quite good at it and as you see in the
film I'm terrible and I'm terrible
because I'm actually Adam I didn't know
my lines in French so it was really
really awkward but it kind of worked out
alright they kind of sort of you know
wrote the scene around it in the end so
that was that was quite funny so you
added acting in French to your CV now I
think I might have to
that one on I mean hopefully nobody will
ever test me on it again but if you were
advising audience to go out and watch
the film why would that be I'd say
because you know it's it's a it's a
feel-good film and you know it's worth
seeing and I think you know hopefully
you'll enjoy at the end of it it should
be a good night
you